le scandale du frioul secoue l'italie la
démocratie chrétienne est impliqué un
haut fonctionnaire démissionne jacques
chirac au congrès des maires rpr si la
gauche gagne les élections ce sera
l'anarchie
ouverture ce matin de la 42e fête de
l'humanité
georges marchais répond en direct aux
questions de noël copains edward gierek
en france indique ce soir portrait de la
jeunesse polonaise rugby à twickenham
les lion's bat barbarians après un match
somptueux bonsoir
avant de développer tous ces titres qui
font l'actualité de ce samedi un coup
d'oeil sur la météo car c'est évidemment
la très bonne nouvelle du week-end je
reconnais qu'il faisait un petit peu
frisquet ce matin 4 à 6 degrés au lever
du jour mais bien vite le baromètre ya
mis du sien pour atteindre vers 14h cet
après midi 17 à 25 degrés température
très acceptable quoi demain soupir de
soulagement tout recommence matinée
fraîche mais après temps ensoleillé sur
la quasi totalité du pays dans la soirée
pour les rentrées du week-end il y aura
quand même quelques petits nuages au
nord de la loire et de la pluie près de
la manche et de la mer du nord
et puis à propos de la manche en deux
mots il faut que je vous parle d'une
petite histoire qui est arrivée un
chalutier français de
saint-vaast-la-hougue près de cherbourg
aujourd'hui il a été abandonné en fin de
matinée par son équipage à une quinzaine
de milles des côtes anglaises
la raison un trou dans la coque mais
c'est l'explication qui est peu banale
il semblerait que ce chalutier a été
heurté par un sous marin qui essayait de
remonter à la surface après une plongée
un incident digne de jules verne
les anglais ont ouvert une enquête pour
savoir si ce sous marin cogneur n'était
pas britannique fini pour les petites
histoires autour maintenant aux grands
titres de l'actualité avec tout d'abord
ce que l'on pourrait appeler le scandale
des scandales en italie comprenez moi
bien
il est déjà choquant pour une entreprise
lockheed pour ne pas la citer de
graisser la patte à certains hommes
politiques au japon
hollande aux états unis ou ailleurs pour
mieux vendre des avions
lorsqu'il s'agit de verser des pots de
vin pour mieux exploiter les sinistrés
victimes d'un tremblement de terre
là c'est profondément scandaleux
et c'est pourtant ce qui se passe dans
le frioul cette région d'italie touchée
il y a un an et demi par un séisme
petit à petit le scandale a éclaté héros
militaire avant-hier le responsable de
la reconstruction du frioul sous
secrétaire d'état à l'intérieur et qui
allait devenir chef des services secrets
a dû démissionner voyez que la sphère va
vraiment très loin mais 1976 la terre
tremble dans le frioul
on compte 980 de mort il ya 80 mille
sinistrés qu'il faudra bien relogés
en attendant que les maisons soient
reconstruites dans un premier temps les
sinistrés habitent dans des tentes dans
des roulottes et même dans des étables
et puis arrive les préfabriqués
il faut près de vingt mille maisons
préfabriquées pour reloger tout le monde
c'est un marché fabuleux d'une occasion
inespérée pour certains individus qui
n'hésiteront pas à tirer profit du
malheur des sinistrés le scandale éclate
le bras droit du commissaire spécial du
gouvernement pour la région du frioul
recevait des pots-de-vin d'une
entreprise de maisons préfabriquées le
maire démocrate chrétien de mariano a
touché 90 mille francs dès les premières
livraisons le conseil municipal a
remarqué qu'il y avait quelque chose qui
n'allait pas par exemple les bulletins
livraisons n'étaient pas rédiger
correctement les factures était curieuse
elle n'avait pas l'air commercial il ya
eu les premières réclamations et puis on
alerte et le commissaire du gouvernement
pour la région du frioul
parce que le commissaire nous avait
autorisé à passer commande à cette
entreprise
personne ne suspectait le merde
c'était impensable ça a été une surprise
énorme d'autant que le maire a prouvé
les réclamations
si au moins les maisons préfabriquées
était de bonne qualité mais non et voilà
un autre scandale une société canadienne
a vendu un millier de préfabriqués à un
prix supérieur d'environ 30% à ceux
pratiqués en italie qui a jugé utile de
passer commande au canada dans quelles
conditions ces containers canadiens
comme on les appelle ici sont dans un
état déplorable comment a t'on accepté
d'y loger des sinistrés regardez tout a
dû être colmatée ça tenait pas j'ai dû
colmater avec du mastic
sans ça il y à l'eau qui entre et
apporte moi les tuyaux pour montrer
comment ils sont tous tordu tenez
inutilisable j'ai dû tout changer de
même qu'une secousse sismique en amène
une autre
les scandales apparaissent au grand jour
les uns après les autres quelque 60
entreprises de construction du frioul se
sont regroupés dans une sorte de trust
qui imposait des tarifs très élevés aux
communes sinistrées
sous prétexte qu'il fallait maintenir
l'activité des entreprises de la région
on a refusé les offres de services qui
provenaient des autres régions d'italie
et qui aurait coûté deux fois moins cher
si au moins le travail avait été bien
fait moi je ne demande pas un palais
mais je ne veux pas d'eau dans ma maison
c'est tout quand il pleut il y à de
l'eau s'oublie il faut une barque pour
entrer dans cette maison on nous a dit
qu'il faudra rester cinq ans dans ces
maisons
on va vers l'hiver maintenant qu'est-ce
qu'on va faire en hiver quand il va
neiger et de faits politiques du
week-end en france maintenant la fête de
l'humanité discours attendu demain de
georges marchais qui dès ce soir en
direct dans notre journal dans quelques
minutes va sans doute nous faire des
confidences et puis deuxième
rassemblement celui des maire rpr de
france ils étaient 5000 réunis pour un
premier congrès à paris aujourd'hui à
retenir trois interventions celle de
monsieur power le président du sénat qui
a critiqué le questionnaire adressé aux
maires par le gouvernement questionnaire
établi à partir du rapport richard
monsieur mono le secrétaire général du
rpr a indiqué que la france fera sa
réforme profonde par un renouveau ou un
renforcement de l'autonomie communale
et puis enfin en clôture discours de
jacques chirac le maire de paris qui
s'adressait donc à ses confrères de
province le phénomène aristocratique
n'épargne ni à droite ni la gauche a
expliqué jacques chirac critiquant les
technocrates qui ignorent la volonté
populaire
le président du werther n'a pas épargné
non plus des comportements
antidémocratiques des gouvernements
successifs de la vème république attaque
aussi contre les partis de gauche en se
demande par quelle aberration deux
grands partis politiques qui se disent
responsables
qui se prétendent de gauche peuvent
afficher en toutes occasions ou presque
leur connivence avec les violations
systématiques de la loi les appels à la
discipline la libération des instants
antisociaux les saccages du patrimoine
collectif
les divagations marginal les divagations
magie nabeul l'épaule offensive contre
l'unité de la nation
on se demande comment ils aspirent à
gouverner
après avoir préparé les conditions d'une
anarchie qui ajouterez à tous les aléas
de leur entreprise
une difficulté supplémentaire dont ils
n'ont vraiment pas besoin
parmi les 5000 maire rpr réunis au
palais des congrès aujourd'hui et qui
écoutait jacques chirac jean pierre
cassabel le maire de castelnaudary
il vit et travaille à 700 km de la vie
politique parisienne camarilla ville lui
a demandé comment peut-on être à la fois
militant gaulliste est maire d'une
petite ville tranquille du sud ouest
castelnaudary chef-lieu de canton du
département de l'aude 12000 habitants
son cassoulet renommée cette collégiale
du 14e son régiment de légion récemment
installé son maire jean pierre cassabel
39 ans militant gaulliste depuis
cinquante-huit secrétaire départemental
et membre du comité central du rpr
députés en 68 il a été battu en 73 mais
sa mairie il la tient bien en plat pays
d'opposition 27 conseillers sur 27 au
premier tour en mars dernier alors on en
vient à se demander si la politique et
les étiquettes veulent encore dire
quelque chose dans la vie municipale
dans une ville de cette importance est
ce qu'on n'est pas très éloigné de la
politique politicienne celle des états
majors parisiens
oui je vous répondrais dieu soit loué
assurément
nous en sommes loin et ça permet de
vivre un groupe scolaire de 15 classes
ainsi été une résidence pour personnes
âgées qui est très vasque véritable
village dans la ville
et puis un ensemble sportif avec des
tennis des piscines en fin de compte
vous bâtissez beaucoup mais est-ce que
qu'est-ce que vous faites de plus ou de
moins qu'un maire socialiste ou qu'un
maire communiste
tout cela c'est un travail nécessaire
mais qui n'a finalement pas grand chose
à voir avec la politique
oui mais alors écoutez je crois qu'il
faut trouver une phrase beaucoup plus
simple et sans tomber dans la polémique
vous avez ici la démonstration d'une
politique ambitieuse qui s'est exprimée
par l'ambition de cette politique qui
s'est concrétisée sur d'un débat sur mer
socialistes communistes plus ou moins
dans l'âme il ya ceux qui travaillent
puis à les autres j'ai deux visages le
seul maire cette ville et je suis très
engagé personnellement je n'ai jamais
caché sur le plan politique mais je
crois on reconnaît que j'ai démythifier
et démystifier la fonction initiale et
que lorsque j'arrive ici je laisse la
casquette politique aux vestiaires ici
nous sommes non pas dans le bureau du
membre du comité central du rpr mais
dans le bureau du maire de castelnaudary
absolument où là il ya un portrait de
jacques chirac derrière vous est ce que
ça veut dire qu'il ya tout de même un
peu de politique dans votre activité de
mer oui le bureau du maire est un bureau
privé
il importe jacques chirat parce que
c'est mon droit de portraits de la
chirac
je connais les maires socialistes dont
le portrait de françois mitterrand mais
je n'ai jamais dit un de mes administrés
regardez bien le portel jacques chirac
et selon que vous le regarderai avec la
us bien de bien bienveillant pas vous
n'aurez où vous n'aurez pas le maire et
dépolitisée ici lorsqu'il rentre et
risoul et dit être le maire de tous et
le militant d'un seul parti c'est cela
aussi la difficulté d'être mère la fête
de l'huma
depuis ce matin à la courneuve c'est la
42e fête organisée par l'humanité le
quotidien communiste
il a été placé sous le signe des régions
de france avec des stands montrant ce
qui se fait aux quatre coins du pays
dans le domaine culturel artistique
social économique politique
qui est gastronomique aussi à la fête de
l'humanité les militants communistes
essaie de concilier les débats sérieux
sur les problèmes du jour avec les
chansons et avec les casse-croûte depuis
plusieurs milliers de personnes depuis
ce matin sont déjà allés à la courneuve
parmi elles il y avait la caméra de
jacques doigts et philippe harrouard
c'est votre un signe le grand cogneur
nous on est arrivé au hasard on a acheté
le programme on va casser la croûte et
puis après on verra oiseaux
d'inspiration des annonces et puis de ce
que je veux dire c'est la première fois
c'est la première fois
inquiète le plus moi personnellement
tout l'ambiance la fête de près par le
fait que ces tireurs fait politique le
sens de cette fête c'est à dire un
combat pour des changements réels ça
c'est quelque chose de très important et
les débats politiques bien entendu vous
êtes en train de politique de santé
vous allez assister à des débats oui
frange ryan débat sur les femmes chômage
épuisé pétrole émanant ils découvrent
tous là
l'énergie ief des vaches alors que
l'iphone commence à tout miser sur
l'énergie nucléaire laissant voir
l'énergie solaire soit prendre tout
l'enfant
sans mise et où les cétacés micro chimie
l'énergie pierce a rappelé aux danses et
les centrales au formula sécurité
légende
donc pour la fête de l'humanité qui
continue demain à la courneuve avec vers
16 heures le discours de georges
marchais mais dès ce soir le secrétaire
général du parti communiste répond en
direct aux questions de noël copains
nouvelle copains vous êtes avec nous
monsieur marché dans quatre jours le
sommet de la gauche ce sera court où ce
sera long ça dépend de nos partenaires
nous nous allons à la négociation avec
la volonté d'aboutir
un bon programme commun de la gauche
comme je l ai déjà dit publiquement à
plusieurs reprises et lors de la
dernière émission à laquelle j'ai
participé à antenne 2 vous avez ce
soir-là parlait même d'un compromis
heures monsieur mitterrand lui a
prononcé un certain nombre de noms
est-ce que vous allez à ce sommet avec
l'intention de prononcer des noms aussi
vous ouvrir largement la négociation sur
le compromis
justement c'est ce qui nous différencie
de l'attitude de françois mitterrand lui
il a dit une fois oui d'ailleurs ça
dépend où il s'était un nom puisque
c'était le smic qui détruit nos temps
dit attendez vous n'avez pas parce que
s'il s'agissait du smic alors par
conséquent il ya toujours de désaccords
sur le smic il a donc dit non sur le
smic il a dit
non sur les nationalisations
il a dit non sur les problèmes touchant
à la défense nationale par conséquent
quand on dit non non et non
alors ça veut dire que pourquoi négocier
nous nous avons un autre d'engag nous
nous disons voilà nos positions dans
toutes ces questions voilà nos
propositions et nous allons à la
discussion
comme j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le dire
avec la volonté d'aboutir à un accord
qui correspondent aux intérêts des
travailleurs et des danses populaires de
produits ou non jusqu à quel seuil
irez-vous ca c il est trop tôt pour
répondre à cette question nous ne
pouvons pas dire ce soir si nous
parviendrons à un accord il faut d'abord
que la discussion s'engage
je vous rappelle d'ailleurs que de
communiqué commun qu'ils avaient été
publiés par lé 15 à l'issue de la
discussion en juillet dernier prévoyait
une reprise de la discussion qui n'a pas
eu lieu puisque de parti socialiste s'y
est opposée si bien que nous allons
directement au sommet sans qu'il y ait
eu discussion pour essayer de surmonter
les divergences ces marchés envisagez
vous la possibilité que cela se termine
par un constat de divergence et je ne
peux pas ce soir
tout est possible tout dépend je répète
de l'état d'esprit dans lequel nos
partenaires vont se présenter à la
discussion
nous nous y allons d'une sur une base
très clair le programme commun 72 avait
besoin d'être actualisées
des progrès ont déjà été réalisés dans
cette voie mais il reste beaucoup à
faire et sur des questions essentielles
puisque ce sont des questions qui
touchent à la vie des travailleurs à
leur niveau de vie à leurs conditions de
travail à la démocratie à
l'épanouissement de la démocratie
notamment dans l'entreprise et à la
dépendance et la défense de la nation
par conséquent sur ces questions là qui
sont si importantes pour l'avenir pour
le succès de l'entreprise que la gauche
veut commencer avec son programme commun
il faut des engagements clairs et précis
marché on a parfois l'impression la
lecture de l'humanité que finalement
pour les communistes monsieur mitterrand
et monsieur raymond barre c'est bonnet
blanc et blanc bonnet vous êtes bourrés
de mauvaise impression
voyez le tarif j'ai quand même des
phrases dans l'humanité disant qu'il n'y
avait pas de changement fondamental de
politique entre les deux si on écoutait
les propositions des socialistes
j'entendais tout à l'heure du
présentateur là il est dans son bureau
là bas et j'aurais bien la voir comme
percepteur parce que je paierai pas
beaucoup d'impôts il voit les choses en
baisse il dit à quelques milliers de
gens à la fête de l'humanité moi
j'aurais dit à des centaines de milliers
de personnes
oui il voit pas bien les choses vous non
plus vous les voyez pas bien parce que
je veux je vous mais je vous mets
attendez je vous mets au défi de trouver
dans l'humanité une phrase qui mettait
sur le même plan françois mitterrand et
et raymond barre
ce que nous disons
c'est que dans l'état actuel des
propositions du parti socialiste
et s'il ne changeait pas de position il
y aurait le risque de voir la gauche
allait au pouvoir pour gérer la crise
autrement dit ignorer le risque que
après avoir remporté une victoire en
1978 les choses continuent comme avant
on aurait changer d'homme mais on
n'aurait pas changer de politique
voilà pourquoi nous les communistes nous
disons il faut bien actualiser le
programme commun pour que de changements
d'hommes correspondent à un changement
de politique
et pour aller dans le sens du progrès
social de la démocratie d'un départ vous
permettez de citer encore une fois
l'humanité il ya quelques jours il y
avait une bonne affaire il y avait un
gros titre la vérité dans la rue si la
gauche arrive au pouvoir et si le parti
communiste le parti socialiste et les
radicaux de gauche gouverne ensemble
serez vous tenté aussi de temps en temps
de faire descendre la vérité dans la rue
pour faire pression sur le gouvernement
dans cette hypothèse à direction
socialiste mais vous êtes con noël
copain est ce qu'elle a été dans la rue
je la vérité devoir une fois c'est moi
qui vous interroge vous êtes tous conçus
par contre l'as v je ne suis pas contre
la vérité dans la rue mais la vérité
aussi la vérité politique s'exprime dans
les institutions au parlement ou et vous
pourrez de vous pour ou contre la vérité
dans la rue je suis pour la vérité dans
la range également pour la vérité dans
les centres de discussion ce que c'est
la vérité dans la rue dans la rue vous
les attendez vous en prie qu'est ce que
c'est la vérité dans la
rester dans la rue c'est dire à notre
peuple que nous considérons nous comme
un peuple majeur un peuple à d'une s'est
lui dit la vérité et la plaie n'est ce
pas à décider lui même
voilà ce que nous faisons et à
intervenir dans la vie politique
économique sociale et culturelle de la
nation
on ne peut pas faire une bonne politique
contre le peuple
on ne peut faire une bonne politique
qu'avec le peuple avec sa participation
active et consciente
voilà pourquoi nous dans la perspective
de la du sommet
nous avons informé des françaises et des
français de la réalité de la négociation
à l'étape où elle se trouve situé
aujourd'hui voilà ces salades et vous
appelez ça la démocratie on a eu c'est
pas une mauvaise formule elle est
incomplète faut dire dans la rue dans
les entreprises dans la cité la
démocratie partout et surtout la vérité
les gens ils en ont assez des hommes
providentiels du parti providentiel des
décisions prises dans le secret des
cabinets et des états majors ni
françaises et les français c'est ça la
grande chose nouvelle
la grande aspiration qui monte
d'ailleurs on le ressent dans cette fête
de l'humanité
les hommes et les femmes de ce pays ne
veulent plus être des pions sur un
échiquier qu'on bouge à sa guise dans
l'intérêt de quelques grands monopoles
ils veulent participer participer
réellement à la vie dans tous les
domaines c'est ça la démocratie telle
que nous des communistes nous la
concevons aujourd'hui bien vous me
disiez que c'est un changement par
rapport au passé
c'est vrai mais je vous ai déjà dit que
le parti communiste avait changé et
qu'il changera encore l'îlot merci
monsieur marche 1000mercis finition
blanche et merci noël copains en
politique encore aujourd'hui réunion ce
matin à paris du conseil politique du
cds de jean lecanuet ce conseil a
approuvé le manifeste de la majorité
jean lecanuet pour sa part a expliqué
qu'il ne fallait pas créer deux fronts
dirigée contre le rp
réponse évidente à jean-jacques
servan-schreiber monsieur jean lecanuet
sera notre invité demain soir dans le
journal de 20h sur antenne 2 pour sa
part monsieur michel d'ornano a déclaré
aujourd'hui sur rtl qu'il serait bon que
le problème de la peine de mort fasse
l'objet d'un débat au parlement à partir
du moment où la loi c'est ce qu'elle est
a dit le ministre de la culture
cette loi doit être appliquée fin de
citation et la loi a été appliquée ce
matin à la prison des baumettes à
marseille
hamida djandoubi 28 ans originaire de
tunisie a été guillotiné
il avait été condamné à mort en février
dernier pour l'assassinât d'une jeune
fille commis avec tortures et actes de
barbarie ainsi que pour le viol d'une
adolescente de 15 ans m polak qui a
assisté à l'exécution de son client
pense que c'est la dernière exécution
capitale moment du procès les experts
psychiatres qui avaient examiné le
condamné avait dit qu'il représentait un
colossal danger social
arrivé lundi à paris pour une visite
officielle de monsieur edward gierek le
numéro un polonais nous vous reparlerons
demain après demain encore et dans les
jours qui suivent de l'importance de
cette visite pour les rapports franco
polonais dès ce soir je vous propose de
suivre le reportage de philippe rochot
et de bernard puissesseau sur l'un dès
problèmes essentiels de la pologne
d'aujourd'hui les jeunes
la pologne est aujourd'hui le pays le
plus jeune d'europe le tiers de la
population a moins de 18 ans et les
moins de 30 ans sont la majorité
ces jeunes la presse polonaise les
appels noé roi l'état socialiste a misé
sur eux pour bâtir ce qu'on appelle une
deuxième pologne car l'an prochain le
pays aura retrouvé le même chiffre de
population qu avant la deuxième guerre
mondiale
34 millions d'habitants qu'est ce que tu
veux faire plus tard
comme tous les ans d'europe
ils veulent être médecin acteurs
ingénieurs archéologues
mais dans un pays où l'emploi est
planifiée ils n'auront pas toujours le
choix ils savent aussi que plus tard
avant l'université
ils devront comme leurs aînés passer
leurs vacances dans ces camps de travail
nous sommes dans un camp de travail pour
étudiants à quelques kilomètres de la
frontière soviétique
ils ont tous 20 ans ils ont terminé
leurs études secondaires au printemps
dernier et près par l'université dans ce
camp ils sont plus de 500 garçons et
filles
divisé en trois brigades agriculture
industrie bâtiment ils reçoivent le
salaire moyen d'un ouvrier 4000 loti 300
francs par mois
ici les étudiants ont pour mission
d'aider les paysans à sauver le grain
après les inondations catastrophiques
qui ont frappé le sud est de la pologne
mais au delà du service obligatoire à
l'état ces camps de travail sont souvent
pour eux la clé d'un futur employeur ce
n'est pas toujours facile de trouver un
travail ça dépend des facultés
pour ma part je veux être ingénieur
agricole et je n'aurai pas de problème
car mon pays et la région où j'habite on
besoin d'ingénieurs qualifiés
espace
et
aujourd'hui la jeunesse polonaise vite
au rythme de bob dylan et rêve de
dollars pour voyager à l'étranger mais
elle voudrait aussi choisir librement
son métier même si la planification de
l'emploi a pratiquement supprimé le
chômage des jeunes on peut pas dire
qu'il ya un chômage parce que finalement
tous tout le monde qui finit les
tous les gens qui sont ici habitude il
trouve un emploi mais parfois on a des
problèmes la jeune fille par exemple la
faculté des lettres ou bien leurs
activités qui sont très à la mode
ils peuvent avoir de problème aquarev la
jeunesse polonaise moyenne à quoi rêve
enfin avoir un appartement mais c'est
possible
non je non c'est pas facile maintenant
c'est un roman c'est un grand problème
en pologne
surtout pour les jeunes trouver un
logement est le problème numéro un des
jeunes mariés kuni chaque jour monsieur
le maire au palais des mariages de
varsovie en pologne
l'amour n'est sans doute plus vite que
les hlm et l'état ne parvient pas à
donner ce qu'il promet un appartement
par famille une pièce par personne on a
promis un appartement à ce jeune couple
mais l'immeuble est encore en
construction et en attendant ils devront
vivre chez leurs parents
et combien voulez vous avoir d'enfant
illégitime
rien
dans la sphère schleyer le patron des
patrons ouest allemands enlevés il ya
cinq jours le dialogue n'a toujours pas
repris entre les ravisseurs et le
gouvernement fédéral
le téléphone de m paillot choisi comme
médiateur possible n'a pas sonné
aujourd'hui les ravisseurs sont restés
muets pendant ce temps une cérémonie
funèbre s'est déroulé ce matin à la
diète de stuttgart la mémoire des trois
policiers a battu à cologne par les
terroristes présents à cette cérémonie
de nombreux représentants du monde
politique ouest allemand dont monsieur
friedrich le ministre de l'économie
démissionnaire ainsi que madame cela
hier la presse allemande a relaté cette
cérémonie aujourd'hui elle s'étonne
aussi des commentaires faits à
l'étranger sur cet événement l'italie
est visé la france aussi en particulier
certains commentateurs allemands nous
reproche nous journal d'antenne 2
d'avoir diffusé une interview de m
croissant l'avocat de la bande à baader
je crois qu'il faut rappeler à ce propos
que nous avons bien expliqué au moment
de la diffusion de cette interview
pourquoi nous faisions en n'hésitant pas
d'ailleurs à prendre nos distances
vis-à-vis de cette prise est prise de
position de m croissant un reportage de
michel meyer a complété l'explication de
cette affaire et enfin il ya eu votre
commentaire alfred grosser commentaires
l'on est sévère vis-à-vis de m croissant
alors alfred grosser comment est-ce
qu'on peut expliquer aujourd'hui la
susceptibilité soudaine de nos confrères
il ya une première chose c'est que la
télévision allemande a eu d'effusion
uniquement de l'interview croissance on
l'a réseau démission il ya eu
l'impression qu'il y avait une
propagande à antenne 2 en faveur de m
croissant mais ça tombe sur une civic
est plus profonde après tout ce que la
presse française a écrit au cours de
l'été on se sent profondément incompris
en allemagne et on a l'impression que la
presse française n'est pas solidaire de
co2 baader meinhof mais en tout cas être
très neutre de ce qui se passe
or la presse française est en train de
changer beaucoup mais il parle souvent
en allemagne de grande liberté de la
presse n'hésite pas chez eux d'ailleurs
à dénoncer certains scandales alors
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils nous
disons que la télévision française la
réputation l'allemagne à l'étranger ne
pas être entièrement libre l'égard du
gouvernement et on croit à ce moment là
que c'est le gouvernement qui a souhaité
cette interview
merci elle concerne transporte
maintenant à monza pour les essais du
grand prix d'italie
patrick tambay a cassé sa voiture au
cours d'un incident spectaculaire il a
glissé pendant plus de 150 m sur le dos
mais il est indemne et carlos rotman
seront en première ligne demain en
athlétisme la cannoise jacky curtet a
battu le record de france du saut en
longueur féminin avec un bond de 6 m 57
en cyclisme l'italien moser le champion
du monde est vraiment véritablement un
as puisqu'il a remporté le critérium du
même nom cet après midi à châteaulin
dans le finistère au rugby dans le match
du jubilé match unique dans l'histoire
de la balle ovale
les lions britanniques ont battu les
barbarians 23 à 14
cet après midi à twickenham la reine
n'était pas là mais le prince charles
s'étaient présentés les joueurs est un
milieu il y avait trois français skréla
bastia et rives la troisième ligne
ce fut de la fois un match engagé
physiquement et somptueux dans ses
essais comme ici par exemple sonata
klein ce maillot rouge
je vais voir bientôt l'arrière écossais
irving étonnant entreprendre un vrai
drame majeur dans les rangs du bail ans
le voici revenu il va trouver en bout de
course
le centre gallois fenwick regardez bien
quelle précision merveilleux fenwick
plongée marque l'essai transformé par
bennett le capitaine lion's et la mi
temps arrive sur le score de 15 à 0 pour
les lion's la deuxième mi-temps verra
arriver superbe des barbarians qui joue
maintenant à gauche sur une balle gagnée
en touche par bastia jean pierre rives
récupère donna kent qui prouve une
touche
très près de la ligne de but brian
balogh barbarians gareth edwards ou sur
ces trois quarts et regardez bien
non cet après midi à châteaulin dans le
finistère
en rugby dans le match du jubilé match
unique dans l'histoire de la balle ovale
les lions britanniques ont battu les
barbarians 23 à 14
cet après midi à twickenham la reine
n'était pas là mais le prince charles
s'étaient présentés les joueurs et un
milieu il y avait trois français skréla
bastia et rives la troisième ligne
ce but la fois un match engagé
physiquement et somptueux dans ses
essais comme ici par exemple sur une
attaque du lion's maillot rouge
vous allez voir bientôt l'arrière
écossais irvine étonnant entreprendre un
vrai drame majeur dans les rangs des
barbarians
le voici ring il va trouver en bout de
course
le centre gallois fenwick regardez bien
quelle précision merveilleux fait louis
plongée marque l'essai transformé par
bennett
le capitaine du lion's et l'ami tu
arrives sur le score de 15 à 0 pour les
lion's deuxième mi-temps verra arriver
superbe de barbarians qui joue
maintenant à gauche sur une balle gagnée
en touche par bastia jean pierre rives
récupère donna kent qui prouve une
touche très près de la ligne de but il a
eu du mal aux barbarians gareth edwards
ou sur ces trois quarts et regardez bien
l'arrière jpr williams qui arrive comme
une bombe
et marque entre les poteaux gerald
davies transforme ce même gerald davies
qui se renvoient des leads
s'infiltre comme une couleuvre dans le
carnet ans regarde la truie drire lui
jean pierre rives formidable il y en a
un pilier i roll on arrive qu'ils voient
marque et l'anglais qui plonge qui
marque un essai vraiment de légende
nous allons revoir aux relents du départ
de gerald ministre capitaine bahreïn il
feinte à gauche à droite il trouve rives
cayla bien placé
encore lui et mackay a marqué 23 14 pour
les lion's c'est fini un rugby droit
pour une reine au revoir à tous on se
reverra bientôt car si roger coderre et
la vida sonnera avec vous les douze
coups de minuit puisqu'elle vous
présentera la dernière édition du
journal d'antenne 2 vers 23h55
je vous retrouve demain avec plaisir je
vous souhaite une très belle soirée